this is
the ramsay show you can be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us
ken coleman ramsey personality host of
the ken coleman show where he talks
about careers and
jobs and finding the right kind of way
to spend your day
is with me this hour to be our co-host
and that means we can talk about your
jobs and your careers as well as your
life as well as your money
phone is at triple eight eight two five
five two
two five triple eight eight two five
five
two two five lisa is with us in spokane
washington to start off
this hour hey lisa what's up hi dave
thanks for taking my call um so here's
the deal
my husband and i were in the process of
building
a house we actually had the foundation
go in last fall
with construction due to resume this
spring
and then we found out last week that our
construction budget went up 40
so we've been on this financial plan to
do this really
intelligently and now it's just gone off
the rails so we're gonna put that on
hold
um due to covid and i have this
big chunk of money sitting in our
savings account waiting to pay for this
home
that now we're going it's not working
for us right it's making
what one percent in our savings account
so we'd love to get your advice to have
some thoughts on
whether to just park in a savings
account we have a rental property
that we owe some money on
we had sold our primary home and i'm
renting a home right now
um it just could use some direction
why'd you stop building last fall
so it's we're building on in a mountain
environment up at a ski resort
and oh you have to weather exactly
so we put in you didn't have you didn't
have your materials and all locked down
by contract
so we didn't i feel a little bit let
down by our contractor honestly but we
did not no so we just found out
literally last week he told us he did
he gave us a revise that's the
difference in your sweet people and me
i wouldn't be a little bit let down i'd
be pissed off like
40 pissed off that was his job to lock
this
up i mean my gosh yeah i'm working with
a contractor right now building a
building or
anticipating a building we're breaking
ground on in two weeks and i've been
wearing them out about locking in
everything because
you can because of the same stuff you're
facing these these shortages on the
materials have gone through the roof
cause prices to go through we're gonna
see inflation come back i'm afraid
because of it
hi so how long do you do what is your
guess
on when you actually do build
wait do you think that it will go back
down i mean you don't know
right i know well yeah i don't know
economists and weather forecasters are
the only people that can be wrong and
keep their jobs
oh and wait a minute medical doctors
predicting virus infection rates but um
there he did he went and they can be
wrong and keep their jobs too
but um uh but anyway the uh uh
[Applause]
for me i don't know i i i i do not i
am pretty sure you're gonna see
something come back down there's a
reason that steel and wood
and lumber and now plywood right behind
it are going through the roof as i
understand it
from the people we're working with in
the business because i've got several
construction projects underway myself
and plywood is actually glue there's a
glue shortage
and that makes the plywood with and so
we're going to see plywood probably
triple in the next 90 days is what i'm
hearing
and it's already high lumber packages
are it's the factories were shut down
and they were not producing uh
inventory supply at the rate even at the
rate that it was going there's not like
there was this huge building spike
and the factories were operating at
normal they weren't operating at
all and then on top of that there was a
good sized spike
in building so as the spike slows down
and the factories get back to capacity
supply demand curve is going to drop
these prices down steel is not going to
stay where it is
not not for not for five years it might
for 24 months though i don't know
i i don't know on that but um
so it so the answer to your question is
how long do you think you're parking the
money
the longer you're going to park the
money the more you're going to want to
put some of it into something like an
index fund
and take a little bit of risk with it to
get a little bit more money
so it could be two to three years okay
so you're thinking i would love it
you emotionally are prepared for a
two-year storm okay i
don't know that you're wrong on that um
so
i'm curious dave how much do you owe on
the rental property
okay so we owe 103 on the property and i
have 180
000 sitting in the savings account okay
when you get ready to build would you be
willing to sell the rental if you had
paid it off and needed the money
if i need to we definitely would do that
yeah
because yeah i mean i mean that's once
that's a really safe place to get a
three or four percent rate of return on
that hundred grand
pay that mortgage off okay ken's got a
point that's where he's going i jumped
the gun but yeah that's that's what you
were thinking
how much money is in savings for this
building project
so i have a 180 in savings and we
already have you know we own the land
outright and we have no debt on
the foundation and done so we already
have you know
a hundred thousand people parked over
there in concrete right now but that's
that's not here there you're not gonna
tear that down so yeah
yeah i i you know you could either do
one of three things or some mix of them
pay off the home
the the rental and then be willing to
sell it when you get her back up because
you're gonna need the cash back out of
it i'm not gonna turn around borrow back
on it
uh if you do that that's kind of a point
of no return on that
the second thing is you could park some
in an index fund index funds are going
to follow the market whatever it does
uh i mean you could lose 10 of what you
put in there over a two-year period of
time it'd be highly unusual
the number of times a two-year period in
the stock market's history is down 10
it's like two percent of the time or
something it almost never happens
but it could i park stuff for short term
like that
if i can afford to lose the spread lose
five or ten percent on it
uh in an index fund and you might make
10 percent
instead of 1 on that portion and then
some of it you park in just cash
and that's your safety bellwether
so i probably wouldn't do the rental and
the index fund i'd do
one or the other and leave the other
half in just cash
yeah okay she got half of it real safe
half of it's either in that rental and
into the or into the index fund
that kind of thing hey thanks for the
call yeah can there the next generation
of elementary school teachers
school kids are going to be uh future
math
it's a whole new form of mathematics is
that right yeah it's where you just make
crap
up yeah i like that well can i just say
this as a parent of three that went
through common core i think somebody
made that up too
[Laughter]
well that's just because you can't
understand it i don't know take a survey
right now i'm telling you
nobody knows what common core is it's
unbelievable it's like they cut it you
got to go out
it's like having a perfectly neighbor
godzilla it's like saying
the front door works but we're not going
to go through the front door because the
way we do it now is we walk all the way
around jump over the fence and come in
the back door
yeah that's common cold it's more fun
for you
i don't even know how that part of your
brain works i don't even know how to do
it i've never tried
this whole side of my head with math
dave it's exploded no there's nothing
there oh there's just nothing there it's
empty doctors have found no wavelength
there's nothing in there no
no activity no brain activity it's
almost like you're a medical doctor
yes you can't do math yeah oh my gosh
this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
he's host of the ken coleman show on
over 75 radio stations siriusxm a big
time podcast and youtube show where he
answers questions
about your career getting a job
getting in the job and in the career
field that you love and are passionate
about
and exactly how to execute and get that
stuff done real world tactics like we're
kind of known for around ramsey
so again triple eight eight two five
five two two
five let's go next to brandy in
wilmington
delaware hi brandi how are you
hi i'm great how are you better than i
deserve what's up
good good um so i wanted to see what you
recommend
i've changed companies um three times in
the past year and i have two
401ks still sitting with the company
that i used to work for
and i wasn't sure what i should do with
them if i should roll them over
or consider an ira what what would you
suggest i would roll them to an ira with
a smartvestor pro they'll help you pick
out some mutual funds
always take your retirement with you
by rolling it to an individual
retirement account in
good mutual funds if you have it
available to take with you
and you do in these cases the reason is
is that your new 401k
at your new company probably is good it
probably has eight or ten decent good
options
but again if you will just put it in
your name a
you've got more control more access
you'll watch it closer
and b you have 8 000 mutual funds to
choose from in an ira
not just 12. and obviously with a field
that wide you can
probably get something that will
outperform or perform equally to
your current 401k but probably
outperform it
okay perfect that was what i thought you
would say but just wanted to check
so thank you so much for your time thank
you so ken the um
what you don't want to do is you don't
have to go back to your old company
and talk about your options and moving
stuff around and
resetting things with a with a hr team
or a payroll team at the old place
it's just uh awkward yeah it's a little
weird
hey i know i left but i've got some
unfinished business oh i need you to
help me out here right
now i need you to do i need you to do
some work for me yeah you should fix
this
yeah that's just and you just get into
all kinds of
issues there so yeah
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five renee is in san
jose hi renee how are you
good afternoon dave thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
i'm 47 years old and i need help finding
motivation to work for another 13 years
until i'm 60 years old
i'm gonna try to preempt your questions
i have about
2.1 million in various 401ks
and about 1.6 million in stocks and
bonds
and a 20k savings emergency fund in my
bank
as i said i'm 47 years old i've never
married no kids
i support my parents who are in their
80s and i have no debt
my three houses are paid off and i've
paid off my medical school loans
i make about 200k a year as a doctor and
in the context of my parental caregiving
responsibilities
i met with a financial advisor last year
to ask
ask how it would be financially if i had
to stop working in order to care for my
parents in the setting of covid
and she said i could stop working and
have enough money to support myself
now if i work another 13 years until i'm
60 years old
i'll get free health insurance for the
rest of my life and i can start
receiving my pension at age 60 years
instead of at age 65 years what do you
like about your work what do you not
like about it
thank you for asking i love my job um
i love seeing patients i feel so blessed
it's such a privilege
if i had to take care of my mom i don't
know if i could work at the same time
i wouldn't want to put her in a nursing
home because then i wouldn't be able to
see her
you don't need motivation to work for 13
more years if you love everything about
it
what is it you don't like
what do i not like well work is
overwhelming these days in the setting
of covid
um i always work more than my paid hours
and i
accept that um if i
truly didn't feel the need to work i
might go to medical uh sorry
music school i i play the piano and the
violin and it's always been a dream
of mine to apply to a music conservatory
yeah you know renee here's the deal
you're a renaissance woman yep
3.7 million dollars you're a doctor and
now you want to go to a music
conservatory
is there anything this woman can't do
you're amazing yeah everybody's going oh
i feel a little bit worse about myself
including me
but renee you know dave's right you
don't need motivation
you need a mission and i think you've
got to say
it's okay i think you have to let
yourself off the hook i i just i've
heard these calls before
is there some sense of and i don't want
to use the word guilt in the in the
normal sense that we use it with a like
you did something wrong but there's some
sort of guilt or shame that you have
when you
allow yourself to envision not being a
doctor because you do love taking care
of patients
but you've got this other side of you
that that you want to explore is there
some sort of guilt or shame you're
dealing with
i wouldn't call it guilt or shame what
would you call it
um lost opportunity yeah all right
so if in the next 13 years i develop
arthritis or lose my hearing
will i regret not having taken the
chance of
getting my skills in place and answering
me and trying
i think the answer is yes that's what i
hear what do you think the answer is
i think it's yes you think you'll regret
it
um there's a high chance i would regret
it i mean there are other outlets for
music it's just that our local
orchestras and string quartets aren't
meeting currently
all right let me ask you this really
quick let me ask you this what kind of a
doctor are you general practice is a
specific
type of medicine you do i i'm an ob gyn
i deliver babies
okay that's awesome so therein lies the
extra hours
right you just you just keep delivering
babies i think you're at a position uh
professionally and financially where you
could you could draw back a little bit
and not work as much as you are and
begin to pursue
practice in half i agree with that and
pursue
get the best of both worlds yeah the joy
of delivering babies that you still have
joy from
and you love your patients but you're
just doing too much of it and it's got
you boxed out of doing other things you
want to do
cut your practice in half you can afford
to do whatever you want to do if you're
asking us mathematically
you're a financial advisor is right you
could quit your job and you know you
figure out a way to live on 3.7 million
dollars i think you struggle through
here
but um but but i i think you get too
much joy and satisfaction from your
medical career i think you just
structured it
to where it's eating you alive it's just
eating into what you really want to do i
think you do what dave says or nate
here's why
let's say you cut back on the practice
guess what there's always going to be
more babies
so you can ramp up this isn't a risky
situation here and dial in a little bit
you know are we going to have a coveted
generation that are all born because
people are at home
renee's the one to ask i think we're
seeing that aren't we renee
a baby boom actually it's the up it's
actually the opposite
um people don't want to be around each
other likelihoods
there is some increased domestic
violence unfortunately
i knew that economically um due to
job loss and uncertainty health
insurance loss
we've actually seen a decrease in the
number of babies born per month
yeah wow yeah okay so people people are
yeah wow i didn't i never thought about
it i just wow
okay so anyway yes i would pull back
i would give you permission to cut your
practice roughly in half or more
the only reason i wouldn't quit
completely is i also think you'll regret
that because i think you get a level of
joy out of this yes i agree with that
thank you for that the three of us are
on the same page so
i used to make over 300k which was my
base pay
and i have given up operating which is
doing surgery on women
and as of last year i did give up labor
and delivery so i'm no longer on call on
weekends nights and holidays so i went
from
full time which is in doctor's world 80
to 90 hours
per week to part-time which is about 50
to 60 hours per week
and um and that gave you that gave you
some relief
yeah but you're still going hard you're
still going hard
and um so i don't know what portion of
the practice i don't know how to parse
out an
obese practice um but um
i would parse it out in some way to
where you cut back to i don't know
whatever you want to call it 30 hours or
whatever i would keep my toe in that
water though i don't think i would walk
away cold
and and i don't think you have to to
explore the music stuff because as you
said
some of the music is coming back a
little slower
than other areas of the culture and so
i got lots of friends in the music
business here in nashville and
they were kind of wishing that it was
going better a lot of them are
struggling
so yeah this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions
on the debt-free stage griffin and sally
are with us hey guys how are you
hey what's going on welcome where do you
guys live we're from milwaukee wisconsin
wonderful welcome to nashville and all
the way here to do a
free screen yes sir how much have you
paid off 148
000 in 15 months whoa that's pretty
rowdy your range of income during that
time
we started out right around 120 and we
finished out at 180.
wow nice incomes what do y'all do for a
living
well you can start so i'm a wedding
photographer and i was a nurse during
our debt payoff as well
okay and then i'm a computer engineer
okay so you were both working
a lot yeah yes well maybe not so much on
the wedding photographer in 2020
well actually a lot of people think that
but it wasn't too bad i think we did
28 or 30 weddings wow yeah yeah
not too many people afraid to still have
their wedding yeah
that's interesting okay well some of the
crowd shots were smaller yeah yeah we
did some weddings that were 10 people
yeah 20 people there but they still
wanted pictures of course yes
that's great yeah a lot of people in the
wedding business quit that's not being
reported
that's breaking news right there on the
stage no there's a lot of people
reporting that they went out of business
that's what i'm saying well
it's not being reported that she's
winning yeah she should that's what they
talk about we did everything in our
power to work with people and reschedule
things
yeah good you what kind of debt was 148
000
it was all my private engineering school
that just got my job yeah wow
so it was all your fault yeah that's how
it started
but we're high school sweethearts so i
was locked in so you knew
you knew what you were getting into huh
yes all right that's very cool
very cool well congratulations very good
so uh what put you on this journey 15
months ago
you can start so about 15 months ago
well not really 15 months ago because we
paid off our debt in october right
and so um in july of 2019 we got married
we were head over heels in love um had
no idea what we had coming for us
griffin is the nerd and i'm the free
spirit so he did all the calculations
realized we had a lot of debt and we had
our first fight
and we were devastated realizing
what situation we were in what this
meant for our future
that this was going to hold us back in a
way we didn't expect
um and so we really both just looked at
each other and felt hopeless
like this is not what we imagined
getting married would feel like
but as much of a burden as it felt like
we knew that
a hard work would get us out of it and
we depended on
our brother's love of dave ramsey luke
over here
to get us through it and so we trusted
god with it
we tithed we honored him in the process
and we just
got to work and we booked as many
weddings as we could
i found another job and griffin um
worked his butt off in the process to
help me
so david said there's a way out you got
to do this hard stuff
yes it was nice and introduce you to us
yes
okay all right very cool way to go david
good job oh luke it's luke
i'm sorry luke said where did i get
david okay i made that up okay
uh my brain just left but yeah so wow
and you did did you sell stuff i mean
you must have lived on nothing
so it was interesting we um when we
started we knew that we were going to
have to cut our expenses as much as
possible
we started cutting each other's hair we
learned how to cut our groceries down to
almost nothing we ate a lot of beans and
cottage cheese
our meals weren't fancy we never went
out to eat we didn't travel
if we were traveling it was for a
wedding and that was our traveling
experiences
weddings became vacation yes somebody
else's wedding yeah
exactly yes and uh what else do we do
after we did the first budget uh it was
red and it was negative
and i said looks like we got to do a
little bit more and so we
dug a little bit deeper found some extra
areas that we were trying to hold on to
and that's yeah that's how it all
started
what were the last couple of areas you
let go of that were hard to let go of
i found it really hard to not do
impulsive experiences like
with our friends we had to say no to
going out
and doing something fun on the spur of
the moment kind of thing
it was really hard to say gotta go home
get to bed because we got work to do
and uh we got a lot of weird looks from
people why are you working so much
that was hard um but it was worth it and
all the sacrifices are what got us to
this point so
sally i want to dial in on that
sacrifice piece as a nurse
and a wedding photographer i mean how
many hours were you pulling in a given
week
so um i was working 40 hours a week
as my nursing job and then we would
travel on the weekends
it just depended sometimes we were going
out of state so we would leave on
fridays
do the weddings on saturday sometimes
friday weddings saturdays weddings and
sunday weddings
and then we would come home griffin
would do all the cooking and cleaning
he was a huge support he went to every
wedding with me
carried my bag made in my job as easy as
possible
and we really worked as a team so i
can't take all the credit but
we did work a lot and it looks like i
worked more but really he was the
motivator
and the encourager and he um did the
small things that i wanted to be doing
but
i realized that those would come later
and now i'm at that point where i get to
clean the house and cook and
do the things i wanted to be doing are
you still cutting each other's hair
uh yeah well griffin actually decided to
grow his hair out yeah that's one way of
saving money right now
in a while okay i think i'll try it in
the last shot i got my hair cut at a at
a haircut places before our wedding two
years ago
so ever since then she's either cut her
it hasn't gotten yeah yeah
fun fun fun how long you all been
married
almost two years in july okay so this
whole thing has encompassed your married
life
yes it was an interesting way to start
for sure you just
yeah the high school sweetheart thing
and then all the romantic bubble is
burst with that first big fight and you
got to go
oh crap there's reality at our doorstep
we got to deal with this exactly
15 months i mean you guys were on fire
thank you this is very well done okay
what do you tell people the secret
to getting out of daddies so the this is
kind of right after we started two
months
we did our first budget realized having
more and we we
realized that we weren't tithing and
there was this big battle of we had to
already trim our budget
and we didn't know is this going to slow
us down by how many months so
in december of 2019 we decided to start
tithing and the next day sally got the
nursing job she just talked about she
got the
or she got a interview and then three
more wedding jobs came in the next day
and we could see the obedience that god
was blessing us for
wow right then and there and we just
kept tithing and we got done even
quicker than we expected so
god is good and he's unfaithful test me
in this says the lord yes
and see if i will not throw open for you
a window
of heaven and pour out blessings that
you cannot contain exactly that's
amazing i think our original goal was
two years
yeah our original goal was uh a month
ago was when we were supposed to end
and then the the more we tied i feel
like the more jobs and the better our
situation got
you know and by the way you got the jobs
you took the jobs and you worked the job
exactly
yeah like a thousand hours i mean extra
wow you just poured it on
great place to go when you're broke to
work you guys are amazing
thank you you're on fire okay so now
you're kind of through the big push
now you got to finish the emergency fund
and get on with the uh
baby step four start your retirement all
that kind of stuff probably already
there now
and so you slow down a little i guess
right yeah so i quit my nursing job
which
oh you did huge blessing because now i
can just kind of
not be the bad kind of normal but have a
more relaxed lifestyle and
and stop and enjoy things a little bit
well actually get some sleep but yeah
yeah
yes breathe a little bit yeah yeah yeah
well congratulations thank you so much
what's the first big thing you want to
do now that you're the other side of
this
well right after we got our day we
haven't seen our emergency fund we got
our retirement started then we kind of
went to trace babies have seven
we didn't have any kids yet and we
didn't have a house we live in an
apartment but now
we're going back to baby step five oh
hey i love it
a onesie yeah baby step five on it
so when do you do uh september yeah oh
my goodness
about a year after we paid off our debt
that's awesome
i got goosebumps everywhere that's a way
to reveal it right that's a great that's
a great baby review it really
is that's fun well congratulations thank
you guys
that is so awesome very very cool what a
great way to start out your lives and
if you guys can plow through something
like this together you can do anything
together
and so it knits you together in a way
that nothing else will
and uh so just just amazing so well done
all right griffin and sally from
milwaukee 148 000 paid off in 15
months making 120 to 180 it's all about
the hours baby
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three
two one
that is fun i love it
wow this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsay show open phones a
triple eight eight two five
five two two five connor
is with us connor's in minneapolis hi
connor
welcome to the ramsay show hey dave hey
kevin thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so hoping you guys can
resolve a
debate between my wife and i on how much
do you spend on a car
um so a little background on us we're on
bb steps
456. we have no debt other than our
house
and no kids yet sorry a little nervous
uh okay what's your household income
what's your household income
yep uh 200 000. and what's the other car
worth
um about 17 okay and what other toys do
you have with motors in them or wheels
on them
uh just one other car that is not worth
a lot that is falling apart
so no no no boats or sea doos
or snowmobiles or whatever
no nothing like that and we have um
currently 86 000 cash on hand
okay so what does she want to spend on
the car
she wants to spend five to six not
nearly enough
that's what i was thinking like 12 to
15.
i would say 20. 25. 20 25. you make 200
000 a year you have no debt you have 86
000 in the bank
you need to buy your wife a good car not
new
but a really nice one-year-old or
two-year-old car
you guys are being cheap skates
well there is a little catch dave um the
one piece being that
in the next one to two years i'm
planning to go back to get my mba
and my wife is a teacher so she only
brings home about 42 a year
so don't quit your job you know your mba
is an executive program at night
why would you give up this fabulous
income to get an mba
um i think long term it's probably the
right move so i went to school for
history and political science and ended
up falling into a really good job
i don't i think you make too much money
to quit your job to go get an mba i
think you get your executive mba
at night it's the same mba dude
and you keep your job yeah what do you
make
uh 156 last year so you're going to pay
156
000 a year for two years to go get an
mba
that's dumber than crap
yeah where are you going what you fell
into something where are you where are
you headed with this nba you think it's
going to take you somewhere where
so um right now i work for a healthcare
rit company um and kind of the second
caveat
with this is that i'm going to be
rolling into a new job in the next year
here
my remote work i work for a company
based out of wisconsin
that works ending so i'll be going to a
new job i don't the income's not going
to drop to nothing
but it should be around the same area
given my experience and
skills and kind of the references i have
um future though i'd like to
work my way up to like a ceo or ceo of a
hospital
i didn't say don't get an mba i said
don't pay 300 000
for it yeah do it as you go
okay i mean really opportunity cost on
your money is one of the things they'll
teach you while you're getting your mba
your pay you're giving up a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a year for two
years of income
to get an mba when you could do it at
night in an executive program
and there's tons of high quality
executive mbas all over the nation
that you can get into and they're about
20 grand and go get your mba mba is a
re is a wonderful field of study is it
necessary to be a ceo no but it's
helpful
it's good i would suggest it i don't
have one but i would suggest you get one
i got several work for me
and um so but you know but dude
you're paying too much anyway side issue
so that's that changes the car
discussion and you're right
that is a a piece of context around the
car on a teacher's salary did we do that
are we going to cut our income by 150
000
so it brings up a larger discussion i
think but um
so i think you go by 20 if you want my
advice if i was your dad i would tell
you
your old uncle that's kind of grouchy
and speaks too plainly
um you know i would say i love you man
and don't pay 300 000
for an mba do it at night go get your
mba live your life
have your career field that you like it
it's probably table stakes to some
degree in the in the world that you're
in
and uh but but you know it is not
necessary for you to give up that income
to get it and that means that you've got
eighty six thousand dollars piled up to
buy your wife at twenty thousand dollar
car
yeah i absolutely agree pay as you go on
the nba
and learn how to follow you're going to
get opportunities to lead that mba is
going to be
real nice it's going to look really good
but by the way if you're working for
somebody a lot of them will pay for it
yes sir they will absolutely if they
want to invest in you a great company
wants you to get that i there's no hurry
for you to go get that
mba yeah there's just no hurry if he's
changing jobs i'd like him to get in and
get settled let's see what the latter
looks like in this new company let's
have that discussion but you know i've
not used this phrase before but it is
the phrase
it is the right phrase we have told
too many people and too many people have
believed
that a degree of a certain level
a degree period or a degree from a
prestigious university is table stakes
to be successful
it's not it's not at all you get to play
at the table
it's how you play the hand and does it
give you an advantage
in some cases it does then you know
having the knowledge base is a good
thing
but there is there is absolutely not a
single piece of research that says where
you went to school caused you to be
successful
matter of fact there's contrary research
absolutely let's give you a good
old-fashioned football recruiting
analogy you can have a five-star rating
or a four-star rating from
from a recruitment organization and you
can get recruited based on that
but you better go and you better show up
and if you don't play well you won't get
on the field i don't care if you're
five-star or not
if you don't play well if you don't show
up in practice
and do what it takes to show it to get a
chance to play on saturday
you won't play i don't care what your
rating is and that's the nba it's nice
it says that you've gone and done
something but the reality is dave you're
right you got to show up you got to be
humble you shouldn't
have to work your way up the ladder by
being a good follower learning how to
lead
and then applying that wonderful
knowledge to real life leadership
and that comes through delivering
results yeah but the the mba is not
willy wonka's golden ticket it is not it
is not going to get you in the ball
cinderella
yeah uh you know what gets you in the
ball is you know
your results yeah you you you actually
do stuff that's right
now it can it get you noticed sure you
know can it get you a side-eyed glance
yes it can
i like that but it doesn't but it
doesn't it does not cause you to get
let me just tell you we're hiring for
you know six figure positions every day
here we're hiring 300 000 people around
300 300 people this year god help me
um 300 is enough at ramsay this year and
several
many many of them are business
leadership roles tech
leadership roles that are six figure and
not a
single one of them will be hired because
of where they went to school
that's true not one not a single one of
them will be hired because
of their career level or be turned down
i mean because of their education level
or be turned down because their
education level
the only thing we are concerned about is
do you have the tools
to do the freaking job
you know i had a guy working for me
years ago said you know guy with as many
degrees as i've got
usually makes any more degrees than a
thermometer i mean you know
he's like a guy many degrees i've got
makes a lot makes x number
of dollars and i said well honey you're
working for a small business and
around here your raise is effective when
you are that's good that's my favorite
line
that's so good but that's you know and
didn't make him happy he didn't work
anymore but the um
you know because he want to be paid for
because he went to school no you get
paid for doing crap
that's it that's all it is scoreboard
kill something
drag it home so in his case the nba is a
good thing good thing
is it table stakes does it mean you
cannot succeed
no would it probably open some doors yes
with the knowledge base you get
definitely open some doors and give you
the ability at a co level to function in
health care
yes and he's in the financial situation
where he can cash flow his way through
it yep
and they might pay for it absolutely i
mean healthcare is big on education so
you know there's a lot of different ways
to play this but what i want to take off
the table for him
and for everyone else is that it is
required
or it is a golden guaranteed ticket
certificate you will succeed because you
have it
no over-educated broke people are
everywhere
yeah they're everywhere they're all over
our culture
and and and they're arrogant as crap oh
yeah but they're broke
here's the line dave a degree is not a
guarantee
that simple touchdown there you go not a
guarantee
it it might it might get you a side-eyed
glance across the ballroom
but that's it cinderella you've got to
make tackles you got to block
you got to catch the ball too many
metaphors mixing up i know cinderella's
making tackles now i don't know this
ain't good buddy
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
ken coleman ramsey personality and host
of the ken coleman show
where he talks about careers and jobs
and how to find fulfillment and the most
money you ever made in your life
and all those kinds of things every day
on 75 radio stations siriusxm a podcast
and youtube all at the same time it's an
amazing feat of technology that that
team pulls off
like they do with this show and you can
join him there anytime you want but you
can join him today here at triple eight
eight two five
five five that's triple eight eight two
five
five two two five and ken we got the big
uh
high getting hired event get hired event
coming up on april the 27th
tuesday yes sir was that a week for
tomorrow yeah you're gonna be here
before you know it
coming to you live from our ramsey
solutions lab we're gonna have a limited
crowd here but it's gonna be a lot of
fun and then anywhere you've got an
internet
connection and a device you can tune in
get hired it's a live stream event this
coming tuesday
the april 2 april the 27th actually
today's monday so a week from tomorrow
uh for those of you listening live uh at
this one night event you're gonna learn
how to get clear
which ken talks about as your first step
is next steps get qualified get
connected get started get promoted
get your dream job and give yourself
away he's going to walk you through the
seven steps of the path
to your dream job and it's time to take
that next step he's going to show you
exactly what to do
why to do it and it's going to feel like
the baby steps but for work
it works has he developed a plan here a
system that thousands and thousands of
people have used to get a different job
a better job
get the first job whatever it is tuesday
april the 27th
get hired live stream it's only 20 bucks
text hired to 33 789 to get signed up
text hired two three three
seven eight nine so what is the emotion
that people will enter
that event with and then what's the
emotion they're gonna leave with yeah
they're gonna
they're gonna enter in a little bit
scared uh probably a little bit of doubt
fear of if i start to make this
transition i might fall backwards
financially
uh doubt is it too late do i have what
it takes
uh and then they're gonna leave with a
tremendous amount of clarity
and confidence and so that emotion is
gonna be wait a second this is not as
complex as i thought
and i can actually get there and you
know what it feels
a little bit um when you're job hunting
it feels a little bit like you're trying
to win the lottery
like it's very random that's right and
it's very
uh but you've got it dialed into a
system where it's not random at all it's
cause and effect yes sir you know you've
taught us so well uh
control the controllables and what i'm
trying to bring to people is hey there's
things you can control
number one you can get clear you can
assess and get great feedback and know
what you do well that's talent you can
figure out the kind of work that fires
you up
and the results you want to put in the
world you can get qualified
you actually can you can do the research
and figure out how to get qualified you
can save up for it
cash or flow your way through it you can
meet people
which are the currency connections are
the currency dave to opportunities
and and you can summon up that
confidence if you do those three things
to actually start you can uh
get better in the workplace you can grow
and you can
earn opportunities to step up so once
you get to the idea that i can actually
do this then they go wait a second
all right so many people think it's the
unscalable mountain
but i was sitting in a green room with
jim collins who wrote good to great yeah
and he had just finished the manuscript
for great by choice
and he was so excited he was just on
beside himself and we've been friends
for years he's a great
he's a wonderful intellect and he was
saying we've discovered
really that that luck is not luck no
it's a choice that's right and he had
shown that empirically with evidence
and research because he's a researcher
it's what he does and he was just he was
beside himself he said it's not random
and and let me tell you you getting that
job is not oh
you're so lucky it is the result of a
series of exact
step-by-step processes that's right that
cause you to put corn
in the ground water the ground back up
let god put the sun
on the ground and then magically you
will get corn
yes but otherwise people just walking
around throwing beans out there hoping
corn grows
yeah yeah you listen if you show me a
person who's confused and been wandering
from job to job
i can tell you that they just didn't
know the direction they were supposed to
go and then there is a path
up the mountain it's intentionality and
those seven stages
are all about intentionality each stage
leads to the next stage and it really is
like climbing up to your professional
pinnacle
and this is how all all men and women
who do what they were created to do
whether it's
whether they're notable or whether
you've never heard of their name they've
all been very clear on where they want
to go and when you have that direction
dave
uh you can find that you know what's
interesting is even if people don't know
they're doing it
everyone who's walking into a successful
career did these steps that's exactly
right without exception
without exception because you just put
names on them yeah and well you i
clearly identified that
here's what the winners do oh yeah well
they even realize they're doing it or
not
i mean there's a mechanic a series of
mechanics to swinging a golf club
throwing a football swinging a baseball
bat and the winners all do it a
certain way that's right it's like well
he has an unusual swing no his swing
sucks yeah and you call it unusual
because he happens to
still hit the ball right but he's still
it's not a it you know
but but there's a reason you call a golf
swing a pretty golf swing it's because
it's mechanically yeah
correct there's a series of things that
are involved in that swing
that caused that to happen as a
repeatable predictable
outcome yeah and that's true in finance
it's true with money it's true with
careers is truly your marriage
and these are predictable outcomes as a
result of behaviors and attitudes and
beliefs yeah
and you're going to outpace most people
when you're intentional
and you know the path that you're
walking on works and it's just a
function of showing
up and i'm going to keep showing up you
know there's two magical worlds that
words that most people don't talk about
when it comes to really pursuing
something that is
i've got to get up and persevere every
day i got to show up but then i got to
be patient
and so we don't sell quick fixes here at
ramsey solutions because
we've read the book dave the tortoise
wins every
time well here's intentionality no
distraction you can automate
applying for jobs yeah and drop your
resume in
sure in the hopper that is playing the
line
yeah and you you but let me tell you
what i'm gonna we're gonna hire 300
people this year
we will get north of 20 000
applications that's extraordinary for
300 spots
now that you're going to do something
that sets you apart some way or another
and king can tell you what that
something is
not just at ramsey but that's the case
everywhere you're trying to go to work
that's right there's something that's
happening
that causes something one of the you can
find
common characteristics of the 300 that
do get hired
versus the 20 000 that applied and did
not get hired here's a hint
a resume is worthless without a
relationship
just soak on that uh with the automation
that's coming on
on the scene in american technology dave
we have a husband is so
distressed he has filled out
applications
thousands of applications and never even
gotten a phone call right because he
wasted his freaking time that's right
you spit in the wind it's not going to
turn out very well so we're going to
teach you how to get connected that's
just
one of the three stages that we'll cover
in depth at night
and it works it works every time so get
hired
live stream giving you some important
content out of that
right now in the last 10 minutes but
even more you want to learn more about
this
ken coleman's going to be doing it april
27th a week from tomorrow
text hired to 33 789
it's twenty boxes off text hired
to thirty three seven eighty nine you'll
spend more than that to add toppings
to your pizza this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
your career and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five james is in west palm beach hey
james welcome to the ramsey show
i appreciate it thanks for taking my
call sure
uh my question was um i have a mortgage
of 165 000
and i have two properties
they're vacant lots but due to like
a lot of people um inventory going up
now
i debated on maybe selling
both of my lots and taking that money
and putting down
on the principal onto their mortgage
i have three kids one's ten one's eight
and one's three
and i have accounts for them but i only
have like maybe
twenty five hundred dollars in each
account and i try to put money and when
they get birthday money
i put the money in those accounts for
them um
toward college uh my question is do i
you know put it toward principal or
should i try to set them up
it accounts for college what are the
lots worth
uh the one lot is about 65 000
and the other y i could get 40 000. both
are paid off
okay so 100 grand and you owe 165 on the
house
correct and what's your household income
115 000 okay well there's not really a
wrong answer
putting it on kids college or put it on
the mortgage either one neither one are
in the stupid column okay
uh both of these are smart huh i'm sorry
it's a 15-year loan i had
okay yeah but neither one are bad ideas
i mean if you told me i'm going to cash
out the lots and
uh go buy a car i would say no i mean
that's it's going down in value the lots
are going up in value
we're trying to think through this so
but you're working the baby steps you're
putting 15
of your income away you're you know
you're putting into retirement you've
got your emergency fund and you're
debt-free but the house right
only in one vehicle i have 14 000 i o on
okay before we discuss anything that
vehicles paid off you have your
emergency fund in place
yes how much i have a total right now 26
000.
write a check as soon as you get off the
phone and pay off your car
okay okay now rebuild your emergency
fund
and then we'll keep on going with this
discussion and you're also putting 15
of your income into retirement already
right correct
yeah so you're doing the baby step
shuttle order oh okay
you were not following our plan our plan
says stop retirement and don't have
savings in emergencies until you're
debt-free but the house but we just did
that so you're good now
okay okay you're caught back up but as
soon as you get off pay off the car okay
yes sir all right good now finish up
your emergency fund you need to add a
little to it the next few months but in
the meantime yeah let's put those lots
on the market and sell them
if i'm in your shoes it's okay to put it
towards the house but i like putting it
towards college
more in this situation because it
doesn't pay off the house
if it paid off the house and you no
longer had a house payment and you could
take that and turn that towards the kids
college fund
really aggressively i'd be excited about
that but you're still gonna have sixty
five thousand dollar balance on the
house after the smoke clears right
yes i mean i just like i did your your
payment calculator to pay things off
early i think
that if you know i did that i could drop
it almost yeah you could get it paid off
by the time they went to school but you
still then would be trying to cash flow
school out of 100 000 income which is a
pinch for three kids
that's a lot so uh yeah i'm gonna just
start
i would sit down with a smart investor
pro and look at how much can i lump sum
into three different kids into a 529
into good mutual funds
to get them you know 80 percent
towards where they need to be at the age
of 18.
in other words a 10 year old you can put
you need to put in x
in order to have y at eight eight years
later
okay and they can tell you what x is and
so you got x for each kid that you need
to put in today
that won't use up the whole hundred
thousand and then i would throw the rest
of it at the mortgage and then let's go
ahead and lean in on that mortgage and
pay it off with your budget okay
okay but since it see what i mean
because it doesn't pay off the mortgage
you don't get any cash flow benefit
today
since you're not knocking the mortgage
out now if you told me you're getting
200 out of these lots i pay off that
mortgage in a heartbeat
my only question was i don't want to be
greedy because i've had this lot
for a while and before 08 and i could
have sold
the one lock with just 90 and you know
that will blew up what is greedy
what do you mean by greedy you know well
back in
i i purchased one property in 2006 and
then
and in like 07 i had a buddy of mine
told me i was getting offers for 90
000 for the one bar i had and i didn't
sell it because
someone was telling me these lots are
going to keep going up and then in 08
the economy you know crashed and i
almost got nothing
yeah i basically had nothing then it was
worthless and now it's finally coming
back so i didn't know if
while you know things are going crazy
right now maybe i should hold on and
just keep failing
oh you don't mean greedy as a spiritual
problem you mean
you you just don't you know the pigs get
fat hogs get slaughtered yeah
okay all right well little piggy sell
the lots
yeah that's all you do it's just time
because
it's not necessarily we don't we're not
making a decision on what's right for
the real estate market we're making a
decision on what's right for james
you're right today your kids college is
more important than you being a lot
speculator
gotcha i appreciate that because i've
been torn my head a little bit yeah
and it's okay to be a lot speculator but
it's secondary to your kids college
right yeah yeah i think so i mean i
think it's important
i would say this that the 529s and you
really understand
what we teach on this because some i
just think college is changing and i
think that landscape has changed i think
parents have to plan for it financially
but give yourself some options so that
money can go towards their training
whether it's traditional four-year
degree
trade school uh or what have you because
the way you get
the knowledge from a four-year degree is
going to change dramatically in the next
11 years i think for that for that
that's what i'm saying but but that's
okay knowledge
knowledge is never going to go out of
style no no no no being dumb has never
been a good idea that's right
so there's a lot of different ways to
get knowledge though and the traditional
four-year model
uh where you have to join a fraternity
is probably
you know between the student loan epic
disaster failure
yes screwing people's lives up yes and
then i'll add to that covet the fact
they're trying to charge the same amount
and send people homework on their
computer that crap ain't going to fly
and so people are done with this and but
it's not but we
at ramsey are not against education no
we just have a realistic view of what
is going to happen to the poor people in
higher education
and uh we have a realistic view of the
actual
value marketplace value of having the
knowledge or having the degree
which is very high it's good to get the
knowledge absolutely and put that money
away parents but make sure that you're
thinking through what's the best way to
apply that
so that your kid actually gets the
training that they need you know the
the sticker price and the return on this
dave as you know is very different yep
chris is in new york city hey chris how
can we help
hey dave hey ken uh great to be on the
show thanks how can we help
yeah um uh real quick i just want to
give a shout out to my girlfriend maria
jose she told me to call in
um reason i'm calling is because i've
got a lot of friends who
are buying into cryptocurrency and you
know my investments are all
in mutual funds like you recommend um
and i'm hearing about
you know bitcoin dog or dodge coin and
all these other things
and i i just wanted your thoughts on how
to respond
when people try to pressure you to
invest into this stuff
and maybe even get your thoughts on
cryptocurrency in general
okay i wouldn't do it why
because i think it's still very
speculative we've already seen big highs
and big lows and i think it's still
rocky i do
think that crypto is coming and to stay
i think right now it's a lot of
speculation
and until it gets adopted and we start
seeing businesses move that way i'd stay
on the sidelines and it's not a part of
our investment strategy at ramsey
solutions either
so there's that too which dave you're
far more versed in that than i am
it's had an incredible year yeah people
made a lot of money out this year
without a doubt no question about that
um but they make a lot of money on
cocaine too
and they make a lot of money on uh you
know playing futures
and they make a lot of money at the
blackjack table and they make a lot of
money betting football
but these are not investment strategies
that's correct these are these are uh
things that you can jump into or jump
out of that are uber
unbelievable high risk and so the
problem is is that people don't perceive
the risk in bitcoin
and it's there it's it's a it's not it's
not fully adopted
they made a lot of money this year i
made a lot of money in gold a few years
ago too and i'm telling people not to
buy gold
and all the gold bugs are going dave
ramsey's an idiot he doesn't understand
no dave ramsey completely understands
i've lost my butt in a bunch of high
risk investments over the years i quit
doing it
i don't like having to start over it's
too expensive
so if you want to start over play crap
that's high risk
if you don't want to start over do what
you're doing but you're not going to
convince friends who are making a bunch
of money that they're stupid
just let them be stupid and smile it's
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
in the lobby of ramsay solutions on the
debt free stage
eddie and lindsay are with us hey guys
how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
welcome where you guys live
st louis missouri awesome and all the
way down here to do a debt-free screen
yes sir very cool how much of you guys
paid off 105
103 love it how long did this take
16 months good for you and your range of
income during that time
uh 120 to 175 000.
wow what do y'all do for a living um i
am a revenue management analyst for
enterprise and i'm a policeman awesome
very cool
very cool good deal good for you guys
well done what kind of debt was the 105
000 uh well for both of us having
four-year degrees it was everything but
student loan debt so everything bought
we had two cars we had
irs debt we had a lot of child support
debt
we had two phones credit cards furniture
so you're like normal you name it
everything but the student loans you
were normal yeah
so how'd you get by with the irs
sorry that would be me all of my
secondary jobs a lot of them are 1099
jobs oh okay and you just didn't pay the
taxes on that i just waited till the end
of the year and made payment plans each
year yeah and they just kept stacking on
each other yeah they do yeah
and it's expensive the penalties and the
interest both are expensive yeah
wow excellent excellent excellent good
job you guys i'm so proud of you
so what happened 16 months ago they got
you on this journey
well actually kind of before that before
we knew you were kind of anti-dave
i came in do you think i came into the
relationship with the
back child support and the back taxes
and then we got married came back from
our
honeymoon and of course my car had over
200 000 miles on it so i bought a car
then since i bought a car the credit
union offered me a ten thousand dollar
credit card which i took
of course then the next year her car
broke so we bought her a car
because you can't have a car breaking
absolutely not and then uh
when that happened we upper that ten
thousand dollar credit card to twenty
thousand dollars yeah
and then uh yeah so i
kind of took over from there um
i grew up wait
stop yeah all right um i grew up like in
a
dave-minded family my dad you know
worked so so hard and gave us a great
life and paid for my college and my
first car and
i still managed to screw up along the
way
so him and i started in this together
once we
actually heard about financial peace at
church and we thought it was a scam
because church are known for scams we
blew past that
and then listened to the podcast a few
years later and it sounded like home to
me it sounded like everything i grew up
with
so me as the nerd i set up our you know
eight
tab excel budget and came to him with
one of my
you know yet another crazy idea that i'm
known for doing but he started listening
and we
both jumped in feet first i sold a ton
of stuff
my coach her gabby's travel volleyball
team so we get the opportunity to do
that but still
save money along the way and then eddie
is the true hero here even with the
political environment that we're in
he worked 80 plus hours a week of you
know on the streets with his police
force and then secondary
sleeping two three hours a day so none
of this would have been possible without
him
wow wow how long have you guys been
married five years on friday
hey congratulations so five years but
then 18 months ago approximately the
podcast started sounding real both of
you jumped on and did it eddie went to
work
you went crazy yeah he i mean he's
always been working
you know a lot of secondary but it you
know the money was just kind of flying
out the window and we weren't sure where
it was going until we put it all down on
paper
and started checking things off and
seeing seeing the progress really helped
you know what's interesting is hard work
isn't as hard when you're getting
traction
yep right yeah i was going to ask
similar question
was there a point where you guys said oh
this is momentum now we're feeling it
do you remember that point in this
journey positive yeah i mean when we
came into it
again you know i grew up with all this
but i didn't think it was possible for
us with the mountain that we had in
front of us you know my parents my dad
was really successful and
you know so of course it made sense that
my parents were there but
for us to do it it just it seemed like
the mountain was way too high
but when we started and you know we
started paying attention to where the
money was going
he was bringing all these huge secondary
checks in and to put them in the right
spot
and see that pile you know get bigger
and you know knock a debt off and then
you know really see that snowball go
was really really exciting and you know
he knew all his hard work was paying off
and all our time apart was
was paying off yeah and it's like one of
the things that you say a lot dave
once we started managing our money right
i got had a lot more opportunities for
more secondary
and more opportunities to make money
that we could put in the right spot
so back back to ken's question a little
bit because i think it's a great
question how far
into the 16 months were you
when you kind of went dadgum this is
going to work
i think when we paid off our consumer
debt and i started seeing that we all of
a sudden we
didn't have consumer debt anymore and we
just had a couple of the bigger
mountains and god kind of kept providing
what were the big mountains the cars
the cars and the the irs that was the
monster we were able to break it up so
we attacked it as we went but as soon as
we weren't seeing those
huge costs how much was it it was
over 13 000 when we started but there's
105 000 so it was the biggest
uh so you had a whole bunch of little
ones we had a whole bunch of little ones
childhood
like like twos and fives and sixes and
fours and
yeah all the way up to to get there to
get to 105 with 13 being the big one
so you really had a very legitimate
snowball effect because you're
you're getting to see this these things
go away all the time all the time
there's another one going away
yeah our list was huge but you know it
they ticked off as we went and it was
yeah i mean almost every month something
went away
yeah yeah that's pretty incredible good
for you guys
so fun all right when you back up now
and you pan out
yeah and people go wow it's impressive
paid off 105 000 how
did you do that what is the key to
getting out of debt
i mean i stared at our budget every day
at work i had it up and i was working
and i'd pander the budget and we'd
watch the secondary checks come in and
it's honestly just every day doing the
small things
and you know putting the money in the
right place and every day
focusing on it being intentional makes a
big difference
yeah if you back up to the big picture i
never thought we'd get there but when we
just looked at every day
they started to add up and go in the
right direction
yeah the little pot little foxes spoil
the vine yeah that's good
as much as uh like we keep feeling the
the little wins as we went
we actually came here in january
on one of her volleyball trips and when
i was here i don't know if you all
remember me not i had a big boot on
because i broke my ankle
and i broke it in december so for the
first time and
i couldn't tell you how long i had no
secondary no
extra income coming in and we actually
kind of freaked out because we're like
what do we do now and we had started
baby step three at that point in time
and we made it through those months
before i was able to go back to work
without i mean we lost uh momentum going
forward obviously
but we didn't fall back any because we
all those bills were paid off we didn't
have all these bills to pay
we never would have made made it through
that number yeah you were dependent on
the second income to survive before
correct
yeah wow very cool guys
i'm so proud of y'all who were your
biggest cheerleaders
um definitely each other um and my
parents were
huge for me okay so did you end up going
through the class at the church after
all
never did we still want to just did the
that's okay just did the podcast yeah
just keep
podcasts obviously since i'm in a car
all the time i listen to you
even still i listen to you non-stop
unfortunately well
well fortunately for me i appreciate it
yeah
so we're going to give you a a a
one-year membership to ramsey plus so
you can go through financial peace
university it's time you did it now
thank you that's awesome that'll be your
your prize for being here today we're so
proud of you guys well done well done
well done
all right and uh gabby survived it looks
like she made it through this process
just barely she just barely
we almost sold her off but she made the
cut we couldn't get enough for her
well maybe you can get her some new
jeans so
bless her don't worry gabby dave doesn't
know that that's a joke
all right eddie and lindsey and gabby
from st louis
105 000 paid off in 16 months
making 120 to 175 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it that's so fun what a neat
couple
a neat family beautifully done this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
miss measure
you pick the wrong color you screw up
like i do sometimes they'll remake your
window blinds free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you can save even more this is an
incredible company i've endorsed them
for years
and i did for a reason they do a good
job use the promo code ramsey
to get the best possible deal today's
question comes from david in new jersey
he asked is it smart to get my doctorate
in physical therapy
even if it costs 100 000 after
graduation i'll make around 75
000 and can cap out at around 110 000
in salary i would not mind working 60
hours a week to pay off this
debt well it is not smart david if you
go into debt for it
um because even though you're willing to
work hard
this is just an unnecessary millstone
around your neck now if you can be
patient
and you can save up this money and cash
flow your way through it
to then increase your earning potential
over time investment ability to be able
to become a
everyday millionaire then it is smart
but until then it is not smart to go
into debt which is what this
uh insinuates to get the doctorate in
physical therapy
so the irony of this ken is is that if
you are in pt
you meet people every day all day long
whose life didn't turn out exactly like
they thought it was going to
yes these are people whose lives were
interrupted by an injury mm-hmm
you have this plan figured out that your
life is not going to be interrupted by
anything
and so i'll just work hard and pay off
the debt
uh let me help you with this your life
is going to get interrupted about the
only thing you can count on
is that it's going to storm about the
you know you can just count on it
and so you know the the assumption of
debt is always a little bit
shows a little bit or a lot of naivete
yes meaning uh well i i can pay the car
payment
says the guy who's getting ready to lose
his job in two months because of covid
or i i can i can afford you know when i
can afford it means
pay the payments these are what broke
people say
wealthy people say i can afford it that
means they're getting ready to buy
something and own it
yeah there's no payments involved it
means two different things
i can afford it if you want to be
mediocre financially means you're going
to go into debt and you hope your little
plan
the best laid plans of mice and men
works out
to your benefit only it won't yeah so i
want you to be a pt if you want to be a
pt
i do not know i'm racking my brain do
you know if you have to have a doctorate
to do that not have to have a doctorate
so
uh this is implying that again he's
hopping out
well he's also i think it's table stakes
and it's not it's not we talked about
this again a degree is not a guarantee
that you're going to
get the job you want or make the money
that you want to make you're still going
to have to put the work in so it's
better off
to be patient save up the money cash
flow your way through
then when you get the windfall of that
sacrifice
uh okay i i don't know i mean i've been
to a physical therapist but i do not
know
what you have i assume you have to have
obviously
i mean i was aware that you got a
master's even yes npt
yeah but i was not i've never seen that
you had to have a doctorate to play
you do not you do not okay so what does
a doctor give you just
access at a hospital that maybe you
wouldn't have i think additional income
opportunities yeah and probably
placement that helps with that income
but you don't to actually do
pt you don't need that yeah there's no
question about that you definitely don't
have to have a doctor this is topping
out the highest level here
uh and again i'm not super aware um of
all the levels of physical therapy but
this implies that you can get the
doctorate but again it's smart if you
cash flow it
sure if that's the level you want to get
to yeah if
his assumptions are right and i'm
starting to wonder now
if this is yeah i don't know yeah i'm
taking my face value that he's done his
homework on this and that you know there
is a doctorate
yeah but every time someone thinks they
have to have a degree to play
i almost always know they haven't done
their homework there's a few times
i mean you have to have a law degree to
pass the bar yes to become an attorney
you have to have an md right or a dds if
you want to be a dentist or a medical
doctor right i mean you have these are
this these are table stakes to play
that's that's the law it is it is an end
you know
it's what it takes to get to play at
that table you have to have a master's
degree in counseling to get licensed to
do counseling in most every state
if not every state now sure and so that
you know having an undergrad and
counseling is not going to cut it
that's right if you want to go into that
world so that that that is
what it takes to be qualified literally
but this idea then that
oh it's going to help me or i'm going to
be successful because that's what you
want to break the back of
and not be stuck on that because
sometimes it could be that instead of
getting your phd you need to open your
own pt outfit and run your own dead gun
business
and have six pts working for you and
that's that's the path right there you
know i mean that's gonna make you a lot
more and stick a phd and it costs a lot
less too
so um but i've got a phd i'm
you know you know well
you do i can't wait to call you doctor
phd and dumb
i know i've heard that line i was
waiting for it i liked it
okay it's grandpa joke theme hour okay
uh having a business can be overwhelming
and lonely but it doesn't have to be
with the right training and support
there's nothing you can't
do business boutique academy is on the
way with christy wright
that's right ladies uh equipping women
to make money doing what they love
christy will guide you every step of the
way through business boutique academy
with her online training group for women
with businesses
enrollment for the academy is open until
april the 22nd
just a couple of more days and it's only
open twice a year
so don't miss your opportunity to get
the training the tools the support you
need to start or grow your own business
join the academy at ramseysolutions.com
academy and become a part of the
incredible community of women who are
making money
doing what they love now christy puts
some real solid
tools in people's belts to cause them to
to to make it work open phones at triple
eight eight two
five five two two five eddie is with us
in waco texas hi eddie welcome to the
ramsay show
thanks so much mr dave how you doing
today better than we deserve sir how can
we help
uh yeah so i had a couple of questions
i'm a young guy and i'm just kind of
starting off on like my
path to life uh i actually just enrolled
in
ramsey plus and trying to learn about
money through your show and your
programs and stuff like that
i was just wondering what are some ways
that i can practice money discipline
in life
well i'm sorry what type of
money discipline what are you saying i'm
confused okay let me rephrase that um so
in the past
money wasn't talked a lot in my house
and i recently
got a financial opportunity where i
significantly increase my income from
forty thousand dollars a year to sixty
thousand dollars a year
way to go dude what are you doing uh
well i just got called up on orders in
the national guard
okay all right and you said you're
nineteen
uh yes sir wow okay well thank you for
your service to the country sir
and congratulations you're doing
something very wise to say
ooh ooh all of a sudden there's more
money than i've ever seen before coming
at me and um
it scares me a little bit uh that's the
that's the the voice of wisdom
you are being very wise people who go oh
i got some money he ha
let's have a party that be some of your
buddies okay
and you really don't want to be like
them so i don't want you to not have fun
i just don't want the fun to have you i
understand
and so really the answer to your
question overall thank you for getting
into ramsey plus
and and doing that but your the answer
to your question is simply this
if you will do what you're doing today
by calling in
and that's pay attention
make every one of these dollars be on an
assignment
as if it were in the military and was on
mission
and the mission can be i want to go out
friday night with this
pretty girl that's a mission and that's
an okay mission the mission can be i'm
saving up to buy a car
the mission can be i'm going to be
generous to this single mom
the mission can be i'm going to buy some
food for my refrigerator the mustard's
running low
i don't care what the mission is but
it's done on purpose
not chaotic and not random
and not impulsive it's a detailed
game plan that makes sense
yes sir so um i was blessed to do a
little training
uh where i got my butt kicked uh for for
a few minutes with the navy seals
last year on one thing and one thing
they taught me in that in a
high impact highly violent situation
like they go into all the time
they spend about 5x
time planning the mission of actually
executing the mission
five times as much time on the planning
as they do actually doing it
so that the doing it becomes automatic
and intentional
and that's true of anyone who's
successful at anything they don't win
by accident this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality host of the ken coleman show
is my co-host today
he talks about careers and jobs which
means we're gonna talk to you
about your life your money and your
career today open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two
five five two two five gina is with us
in san francisco to start off this hour
hi gina how are you
hi how are you dave i found you on
youtube and found your um
your pup so very very informative
thank you so my husband died three weeks
ago
oh my gosh yeah cancer
oh how old was she 38
only oh how old are you
i'm 35 how long were y'all married
about eight years oh baby i'm so sorry
three weeks ago so you guys have been
through a long
struggle hadn't you
it was it was a you know beautiful
marriage and
not so much struggle no i mean with this
i mean how long was how long was he
with a cancer diagnosis
oh two years it was a it was a rough
fight
yeah that's what i mean
so um my question is what should i do
with three things that he loves us he
has life savings
an insurance payout and a 401k
um to protect it from inflation
that's my goal yeah what is your advice
ah okay so how much life insurance
life insurance um well
we'll probably get around
20 to 50k okay because um
how much was it how much was in the 401k
401k around 20k also
and you did you say life savings is that
what you said
his savings because we we didn't really
have a joint
right how much was in the same 100 how
much
200 200 000 what is that in just a
savings account
yes i already um closed it and
put it on a custodian account which is
my son's
you put it into your son's name
my son and my name so it's a custodian
account under both of our knees
okay a custodian account is open for a
minor
the custodian is not the owner custodian
is the manager
and if the only way you have a custodian
account it is not in both of your names
because you can't do a custodian account
for an adult
right i'm the manager so you put it all
into your son's name
and you're the custodian when did you do
that
um in the last three weeks right
yeah yeah okay all right um
okay uh um
all right the first thing is is that we
want to make as few big decisions
while you're while this
um event while this pain
is so fresh okay because
um if my wife passed away three weeks
ago
i make money decisions for a living i
teach people to make my decisions for a
living i'm not making any big decisions
in the first three weeks
i'm just gonna cry i'm just gonna cry
okay you don't you know you're in the
fog of grief no
human being's brain works well okay
but you're gonna have to go ahead and
make some decisions because you made a
bad one this this move to this custodian
account needs to be undone
very very quickly because you've made up
you you've made a mess
and i'm not picking on you don't
misunderstand but you cannot
move money of that size from one
individual to another individual
like your child for instance without
gift tax and so you're
you've gotten yourself into a problem
here and i don't know who told you to do
this but they were not giving you good
advice
and and that money doesn't need to be in
the child's name anyway it needs to be
in your name
because it's your money and you need to
be managing and yes we're going to take
care of the child that's what mommies do
and daddies do
but uh the money does not the bulk of
your net worth does not need to be in
your child's name
that that's a mistake okay and and so
what i am going to direct you to do is
go to daveramsey.com and click on smart
investor
and you'll you'll find some people in
your area that we recommend that have
the heart of a teacher and they're going
to teach you
what to do next gently calmly and you're
going gonna understand it before you do
it and you're gonna
i mean this week kiddo undo this because
i don't want that i don't want the irs
getting wind of this
i don't want you to get hammered with a
gift tax here
okay okay so we do our
or you can park it just in a money
market while you cry a little and then
learn about investments later
but you don't have to be sophisticated
three weeks after your husband passed
away honey
give yourself a little room okay all we
have to do is keep the lights on and
keep
groceries in the refrigerator that's all
we gotta do right now
now what about the insurance and the
401k same thing
same thing i want to spend and make no
big decisions if
at all possible for about six months i'd
like to just sit in a
i'm not worried about inflation for six
months i'm worried about grief
okay and um this is what i personally
would do
if my daughter called me who's your age
and said that
something happened i would say listen
what we're going to do is do the least
number of decisions we can do for six
months and we're just gonna cry
and then when and every day that goes by
your brain will get a little bit clearer
and a little bit clearer and a little
bit clearer and it'll always hurt
but 25 years from now it won't hurt as
much as 25 days from now
does that make sense
yes and i'm not saying you're an
incompetent person i'm saying you're in
an in a situation where you don't need
to make big decisions
you can if you want my advice is to not
do that though
so i would sit down with a smartvestor
pro i would move it all into a money
market account
you can roll the 401k into an inherited
ira
without any trouble at all you're the
beneficiary on it you can move it it'll
have no taxes on it
they can show you how to do that and you
don't have to make a bunch of big
investment decisions
now later on i'm going to go into mutual
funds
after my after everything clears in my
brain i
personally invest gina into four types
of mutual funds growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international
and i spread it evenly across those if
you do that you will outpace inflation
considerably
uh inflation has run 4.2 percent for the
last 75 years according to consumer
price indexes cpi
and that's our measure of inflation
we're probably getting ready to see some
new inflation so it's wise to think
about
outpacing it with these uh building
shortages that we've got supply
shortages and things now we're going to
see a little of that come back
for the first time in a couple of
decades really but in the mean but
you're still gonna be okay
you gotta out you gotta make more than
about six percent on your money to be
taxes and inflation
to break even taxes are gonna take up
about two percent
inflation's gonna take up about four
that's six so if you don't make
over six you're breaking not breaking
even taxes and inflation
but that's your long-term play kiddo
it's not the next six weeks
not in the next six months i'll tell you
what hang on kelly will pick up and
she'll get
you with one of our coaches for free we
won't charge you anything and then
get you with a smart buster pro and walk
with you through this i'm so sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
while our famous ten dollar sale is back
get the tools and resources you need to
make
real progress with your money and your
life goals
all for just ten dollars a book that
means saving up to 60 percent
on over 40 best-selling books like the
number one bestseller the total money
makeover
or ken's book the number one bestseller
the proximity principle
about getting the job you love these
also make great gifts head to
ramseysolutions.com
store check out the 10 sale these are
hardback number one best-selling books
in almost every case all bestsellers
for 10 each and there's more we've got a
gift for you too you can enter to win
our ramsey cash giveaway we're giving
away
500 cash every week starting this week
plus a grand prize of 5 000 cash
so enter daily for extra chances to win
no purchase necessary you got to be 18
or older of course text
cash to 33789
and check out the 10 sale at
ramseysolutions.com
store michael is with us in detroit hey
michael how are you
i'm welcome to you how are you doing
today sir better than i deserve
how can we help so
i'm um i'm very thankful and fortunate
for on that um
i've saved and scrimped a lot in my life
and
i have a pretty good savings and um i
grew up in a very very poor household
and it was homeless for a while
and i'm debt-free and i'm too concerned
that i'm not
maximizing what i could be doing um
my goal really is to leave behind some
generational wealth for my children
um but i'm pretty nervous when it comes
to real estate
especially i've been listening to a lot
of folks whether their homes you know
people aren't being forced to pay their
rent and then
the people that own these properties are
you know losing them so i'm just looking
for some guidance
on you know what someone in my position
could do
i'm sorry what to do with what you want
you want to build generational wealth
and people are losing their houses
because they don't pay rent i don't
i don't understand yeah so so look for
for a better investment so
you know right now i'm maxing out my
401k to the
legal limit and i've got some um i've
got some you know investments in some
mutual funds but
i'm not really especially uh assumed i
guess in investing
um and so i'm i know that you speak a
lot about real estate
um but i was wondering if you just had
any guidance on you know how to
how to maximize um returns if you're a
little skittish on on real estate
okay i um if you're asking what to
invest in
number one all investments have a level
of risk
period and that means there's unknowns
that means things are going to happen
that you can't predict
and that are going to that obviously if
you knew a negative thing was going to
happen you would not be in that
investment we all would avoid that
that's obvious
but there are all all every single
investment has a risk okay
now let's start with like a savings
account you could open a cd
and make one percent on your money and
you don't have any risk
oh yes you do wait all investments have
risk
what's the risk of having making one
percent on your money well we just
talked about a minute ago inflation runs
four percent
4.2 and taxes are going to take
a fifth of what you make a fourth of
what you make a third of what you make
okay and so you got to make six but
you're only making one
and so you are losing five percent a
year in purchasing power
when you save money at one percent so
you just picked a risk
a an investment that you thought had no
risk and you pretty much guaranteed a
loss
in purchasing power okay so that one
doesn't work that's one end of the
spectrum the other end of the spectrum
is doing high risk things
where you lose all the money and you
play you know you go to the roulette
table
or you play bitcoin or you play gold
or you play uh you know you bet football
or i don't know whatever you want to
call these things that are gambling
in essence and you hope that you hit
and you think that you're the exception
and you're going to hit and we don't do
that one either
so what we do play in is in the middle
uh and in the middle i found two things
that i'm comfortable with the risk
and with the returns and that's real
estate which has some risk the renter
may not pay
the house may burn down it may get
flooded a tornado may hit it a tree may
fall across it
um some government agency may lose their
dead gum
mind and decide covet means that they
have the right to take over the freaking
world
oh wait that just happened and so uh you
know
they shut down you know i had a guy in
one of our properties who was beating
his wife drinking and tearing up
everything had nothing to do with covid
it had to do with he's an idiot and we
couldn't get him out because they had a
moratorium on evictions because of covet
in tennessee that's been lifted thank
god and we got we tossed that piece of
trash out
um bless his little wife's heart you
know
oh god what a mess and so you know but
this is a risk of owning real estate
and people say well i buy real estate
renters will always pay
anything about renters so uh you know
some
do some don't and you do your best just
like not all employees work hello
and so um this is these are risks you
take so you assess the risk versus the
return
and you accept the risk pretty much know
you're going to have some of it
and that goes with the returns and if
you measure that out that's what wealthy
people do
and so i buy real estate and accept the
risk and i love the returns i buy mutual
funds and i accept the risk
and i don't and i look for the returns i
don't buy single stocks
a valid investment but too much risk for
me
but versus the return i get i i've been
broke and i don't need to lose my money
and so i don't put all my money or a
bunch of my money in one company
uh although had you put it in apple you
would have done well had you put it in
microsoft you would have done well
but i don't do that i've got friends
that have done all kinds of single stock
investments and
it's like a fishing story they always
talk about the one they catch right they
talk about on the golf course right oh
sure
and they always got a story so but it's
a risk analysis
michael that's what you learn to get
used to there is no
formula where you don't take risk and
you make money
doesn't exist yeah it just comes down to
how much risk you're willing to take and
again i want to dive a little deeper on
that because i know that advice and i've
heard you give it many many times
you're not saying that it's it's wrong
to do but it's just really really risk
and you've learned over time
with your track record of investing and
the appetite that you had for risk
coming out of getting
debt free i'm just not going to play
that game it's not worth it
and that's that's really what what we
need to hear i mean you could certainly
invest
in a single stock but you got to be on
top of it or you lose your shirt you got
to really know what you're doing i mean
i could take ten thousand dollars and
put a slot machine
right but i just don't i just don't like
the payout probability
and that's really important yeah and uh
but that doesn't mean
that doesn't you know doesn't mean you
sometimes you don't hit on a slot
machine
right but i guarantee you i do know who
hits on the slot machine yeah the casino
oh yeah
they make money on them every day yep no
one else does yeah
so i mean you start to learn these games
and you go that's the game this is going
to miss the game so i'm going to measure
the risk versus the return
and i'm going to accept the risk to get
the return
and if you don't take enough risk you
get tackled from behind by inflation and
taxes
if you take too much risk you you lose
your money
i'm going to ask you this when you
invest into real estate of course now
you're
paying cash here so we're talking about
cash investing in real estate
what are the risk meters you run through
before you buy a house that you're going
to rent
what are you looking at are you looking
at neighborhood of course you look i
mean what are some of the things that
people need to think through
well the first lens we look at is you
make your money on the buy
right and so is it a bargain mm-hmm
which there's nothing bargains right now
right
market's white hot you're not a steel
you know we bought a lot of foreclosures
we bought a lot of stuff in 2008 when
the market went down all that
but there's no there's no bargains in
real estate right now so i'm not buying
real estate right now i'm building some
but i'm not buying any
um and so uh the thing is the
um you know i'm looking at the bargain
on the front end
that helps me yeah because that lowers
your risk then so if you've got a
property that's worth 300 000 and you
pay 180 for it
you just limited your risk yes and now
then obviously you got to look at the
property and go is this marketable
i mean if it's a weird twisted up floor
plan that's not rentable or resellable
then there's a reason it was a bargain
it sucks right
you know so you just gotta you gotta use
some common sense and go
somebody walks up to this or they're
gonna wanna rent it somebody walks up to
this later and i wanna sell it are they
gonna wanna stop by
and so we're looking at the curb appeal
the quality of the property the location
of the property
um you know you know and and then what
are we going to rent it for
what's the rental market versus what we
pay for it and that's your return on
investment it's a fairly simple equation
and so but there's a lot of common sense
that's why it's good to buy real estate
in your area because you
inherently intrinsically know the area
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
jarrett and laurie are with us hey guys
how are you hey
dave how are you welcome it's so good to
have you guys where do you all live
uh we live in houston houston texas
welcome to nashville very cool and all
the way to nashville to do a debt-free
screen
yes i love it how much have you paid off
uh
six hundred 419 ninety dollars i love it
and how long did this take four years
four years
and your range of income during that
time between 250 and 350.
yo y'all are killing it what do you all
make what do y'all do for living oh uh
so i'm a nurse anesthetist and my wife
is a dentist
oh nice career choices ding ding
well done i love it so four years 420 i
was going to say house but when you told
me your careers i'm going to say student
loans
yeah pretty much eighty percent of it
was all student loans a lot of student
loans
and the dentist usually more absolutely
well actually i
i had a lot from anesthesia school okay
so i had a lot from school so about even
then huh yeah about even yeah all right
couple hundred each
yeah yeah but you're making bank now
wow well i'm so happy you guys well done
okay so how long have you been out of
school
uh so i graduated in 2011 and then
i graduated in 2004. okay so you've been
out a while you're bopping along
making some money but this monster is
hanging behind you
yeah dark cloud is following you
everywhere that's the thing with student
loans like they just follow you and
follow you and then so
what what woke you up you said we're
gonna kill this thing monster be dead
uh it was really my wife just one day
she just got tired of
you know me always buying stuff and you
know you just you get paid because you
feel you deserve it and you're trying to
keep up with people buy nice cars you
know go place a vacation
so one day uh she said hey you want to
go on a date with me and i said yeah
let's go on a date
and then she's like when i get there you
know you're there it's like a smart
money conference and that's out of
trouble that's
wrong that is wrong she totally just i
was like oh i thought we're going to
date and it was it was like a one day
conference
hey you had to sit there listening to
this guy
all day i gotta know hold on what at
what point did you know you were going
to a conference was it that morning
no it's like i pulled up i go in and
like we literally we start walking to
the building i said hey is this like a
conference and she said yeah it's like
it's dave ramsey smart money is
something
so you know it's cold it's very smart
and probably about four hours into it i
started i was like you know what you're
right like
we really should get on a budget you
know i've been spending too much money
you're right we need to
you know communicate communicate more
and uh you know
just drunk the kool-aid so after that
what year was this
this was uh 42007 so it was it was a
smart
conference yeah smart conference yeah
money was just part of it
yeah absolutely yeah we had everybody
else there yeah so you had a rachel was
there
inky johnson yeah yeah i remember that
one yeah
rice church yeah yeah absolutely inky's
a great speaker yeah it was amazing
and then after that so then we started
looking for fpu so then we got an fpu at
our church
um our you know our fpu mentors like
just
walked us through we even went again to
fpu after that so like they
like they really supported us the whole
time because four years it was a
it was a long drag yeah you are a
patient man i
i i i'm pretty calm with sharon i'm not
sure if she tricked me like that i'd
have been okay with that
yeah but it was well you did well you
did well he's amazing
that's cool yeah you had a lot of trust
in her yeah
very cool yeah let's go on a date
all day long
wow but it changed your life change
changed my life and then after that i
mean even our fpu just just kind of
going through it because then you go to
the conference and you're like okay well
let me get into it
and then that's nine weeks and our fpu
mentors yolanda and stan and they walked
us through and
you know you start using cash for
everything you you
try to i mean we did everything try to
change our cell phone bills how far
were you through the 420 000
before it kind of clicked and you went i
thought this was going to work but now i
know it's going to work
well see that's the because you
intellectually get it yeah
yeah then that's like why you always say
like yours like it's common sense
you know it makes sense but just it just
kind of just comes like one day you
realize like
you're spending cash for something
you're not buying stuff you're not going
on trips for me i used to buy tennis
shoes all the time like
you know spend 100 on some you know
jordans or whatever and then just one
day you just realize like hey
this money is actually going down like
this interest is is moving
so it just kind of sneaks up on you like
it's it's kind of cool do you remember
uh uh lori where you where you were in
the numbers
before you went well this is actually
going to work it clicked for me when
we paid my car off and i was driving my
car around with
no and you know no i that never had a
car without a note oh
yeah so that is when i said this is
freedom
yeah this is it right here and you lean
in even harder
yes yes yeah that's fun man you guys are
impressive
i mean impressive incomes and careers
but i mean what a lot
load of debt and you did it in four you
paid off a hundred thousand dollars a
year average for
four years yeah it was rowdy
what did you do to increase were you
working more hours uh yeah so
some days i was working six days a week
i was working 24 hour ob shifts i would
do
gi shifts sometimes uh just work work
work
work work work work there's no shortcut
is there no
shortcut you just work and then you know
the other part of it is you just stop
spending money you you know you just
you can't spend money because you're
working yeah you're not you're working
yeah so that's a good point
yeah yeah yeah so you just keep going to
work and you just spend less money you
try to figure out you know get rid of
your cable
we did the streaming thing we did low
cell phones
uh you know once you get rid of your car
note and you start and that money is
yours you're like wow that's a that as
a snowball so you just keep you know
pushing along yeah
and that was all ours yeah yeah i mean
four years later you you break through
and you finally finish how did it feel
yeah i mean like what'd you say
invigorating
invigorating was go to on a ski trip and
just
wild out yeah why not yeah you're making
you're making three you're making 300
grand you got no payments
yeah where did you go where was your ski
trip we went to keystone colorado yeah
that's nice
keystone yeah yeah they they they used
to have night skiing do they still we
didn't get a nice game we taught
ourselves to ski on youtube
oh yeah
like for those sharp young men right
there who went through all this too
you know they were with us the whole
time because we when we went to fpu was
at church so we would bring them with us
so they sat in the back and then so we
went to fpu twice with them
they listen to you all the time like
even we're sitting here in the lobby and
they're like oh dave ramsey like we know
this music because
the podcast is always on in the car so
they've been with us
i mean it's pretty much feel like their
whole life they're 12 now
so you know we started they were right
yeah they're yeah they're eight so they
were just like
oh they're twins yeah they're like
awesome okay what are their names
so this is uh shawn right here
i'm looking down yeah yeah this is an
eight yeah
oh that's so cool you guys very cool all
right when people ask how you did it
what do you tell them the secret to
getting out of debt is
uh budget 100 like if you don't know
where your money's going you're not
gonna
you're not gonna know where your money's
going so you know you just gotta got a
budget
uh communicate be on the same page we
would have budget meetings and they
would be fun
i started doing spreadsheets and you
know they were
yeah like we just made it fun like we're
like oh this is where this is where
we're going to do with our money so
uh that's the number one key once you do
that and then you commit to it it's
gonna
it's gonna it's gonna happen yeah you
know i i do notice a lot and i don't
know that we've ever said this out loud
a lot but i notice a lot with the debt
free screams that
uh it's not unusual to hear you kind of
make a game of it
once you get to a certain point and the
desperation starts to fall off and the
hope starts to come it's like okay this
is like it's like a game how fast can i
do this it's like
you know i'm trying to beat a video game
or something you know it gets that
same kind of thing happens starts
happening in your head and it's like he
started doing that that spreadsheet he
had that look you know what i'm talking
about he's like
yeah yeah yeah cause you start to feel
it and you go yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
beat this thing i'm going the next level
yeah
absolutely very cool very cool you guys
so well done and so you had all kinds of
encouragement from fpu you told you
mentioned your
mentors yeah that's good that's your
biggest cheerleaders all right
all right nate and sean baby four years
coming debt free scream you've been
hearing them
now you are one get ready to do it whole
family tree has changed
your mom and dad are absolute heroes man
you guys are rock stars it's an honor to
meet you
420 000 paid off in four years making
250 to 350.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
one two three four
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day second
ephesians 2 10 for we are god's
handiwork created in christ jesus to do
good works
which god prepared in advance for us to
do
c.s lewis said you are never too old to
set another goal or to dream
a new dream it's an interesting
thought from ephesians there can which
god prepared us
in advance or god prepared in advance
for us to do
good works yeah and you know you always
say
you're put on this planet to do
something you don't do it somebody's
missing out that's right
you were created to work and you're
created to do some
you know you're giving a certain set of
skills and god's got a certain thing in
mind
now it's not if you miss that one little
nuanced thing that you missed god's will
we're not fatalistic about it right
but there you know there's a range of
options but you know you're put here to
do certain things with your gifts and
talents and if you don't do them
then the culture society that's right
the nation the world is let down
that's right your purpose isn't actually
about you your purpose is to give
yourself away you were gifted
with something to give away and you know
look if you take the word work out and i
say created to contribute
people go okay now i can buy into that
his work's at this nasty ugly word about
it unfortunately because of the toxic
view of work in this world but
yes rabbi lapin uh
orthodox jewish rabbi who wrote um uh
uh thou shall prosper i can't get it on
my mouth um
it says that the jewish view of work is
very similar to the jewish word for
worship
that the way you do your work is a
method of worship
and i love that yes that picture that's
a beautiful thing
so ken is doing a week from tomorrow
night
the um get hired event
it is a live stream this coming a week
from tuesday
night it's 20 and if you want to view it
we've got a few slots here live in the
building
for a live studio audience purposes but
just a handful if you're here in the
nashville area and want to come
if you want uh to view it and people are
going to do that literally
all over the world tickets start at just
twenty dollars and you uh can
text hired 233 789 to learn more
the get hired event tuesday april the
27th text
hired 23789
courtney's in birmingham hey courtney
welcome to the ramsey show how can we
help
hey dave hey how are you better than we
deserve what's up
um so first off i'm gonna say you
have completely changed my family's life
you completely changed our life
and pretty much everyone that we know
thinks we're a little bit
crazy so i guess that's good
but my main question to you is this
is my husband has been put in for a
promotion
and with that being said they are giving
him a car
allowance and there are requirements on
the year
and the the model and such so
everything i'm looking at is a
ridiculous amount of money for a car
um what does he do we're not so he would
be as
like a sales rep for heavy equipment
okay that's what he would be going into
that's the promotion they put him into
which is great
you know substantial amount of income
increase
but we're in baby steps four five and
six what is the uh what are the
requirements on the car
so it has to be maximum is five years
um that it has to be and then under 120
000
we we drive old old cars
what is he going to be making um so he
would be making
um starting out on scholarship he would
be making
right at 60 000. what's scholarship mean
um before he goes on commission when
he's on commission what will he be
making do you think
um the guy that was in the area before
him
was bringing in between 80 and 100. okay
what does he make now
right now he makes 42. okay cool
and um you don't how much money do you
have in savings
right now we have just baby step three
which would be 15.
okay all right and when will they be
moving him into this role
may 1st okay all right
so he needs to negotiate with his
supervisor to give you time to save up
to buy a five-year-old truck
okay and because that's what he's going
to be wanting he's out
calling on heavy heavy because here here
but here's your rule
you always want to drive the cheapest
car possible
to get the job done now you're going to
lose
money on the car allowance how much is
the car allowance
so the car allowance is 600 yeah you're
going to lose money
yes that's only 7 200 a year and a
stupid 20 000 our truck is going to go
down
that much as many miles as you put on it
absolutely
okay so the car allowance is not a
blessing it's it's it's not a benefit
now they walk around strut around with
their chest stuck out like it's a
benefit it's not they're ripping you off
it's a bad deal
the good news is he's going to triple
his income and so it's probably worth it
okay but the car allowance sucks i would
rather them give him a truck
as a company car as a company just give
me a company car and keep your 600 bucks
you would come out a lot better that's
this is the reason they don't do it
yeah yeah and 600 is everywhere lots of
people have 600
car allowance so but you're going to
lose money on that with a loss in value
not to mention everything else that
you're going to have
so what you've got to do is you have to
continuously fund
a move up every few years in truck
to stay within the guidelines right
and so out of your overall income which
includes the six hundred dollars but the
six hundred dollars is just part of your
income
you keep saving money to move up in
truck every so often
and you keep a a four five six year old
truck
and uh because whatever he's driving he
is destroying its value because he's
putting a bazillion
miles on it and he's on rough sites so
he's really putting hard miles on him
yeah so whatever he drives it's a cost
of
the job so you're gonna lose
10 15 000 a year on this operation
and you're going to receive seven
so just kind of count on that that's
okay i'd still do it
because i think the promotion's big
enough to justify it but if they were
giving him a 5 000
year raise i'd turn the promotion down
okay because it's not that great a deal
on the car part of it the car part's a
bad deal
okay but go ahead and talk to your
supervisor and say it's going to take us
a little while to save up 20 grand we
don't have it and we don't borrow money
well just use your car allowance to pay
the payment no because if i ever lose
this job i still got the stupid payment
and i don't have the job anymore
so you don't use your car allowance to
pay payments so
i'll get a truck as quickly as i can the
meantime i'm driving this
and i'll get one probably about
september or so or whenever it is you
can save up the money right
yeah you work outside the home i work um
inside the home but i do what's your
household income insurance
um right now before the raise it would
be 80.
so it's going to be 100. so doing that
you can save up to get a 15 20 000
truck that'll meet the guidelines barely
pretty quick
but you're going to have to you won't do
it by may 1 so they're going to have to
give you a little grace and they will
if you just just stand just stand with
your heels in the ground and go no i'm
not doing it
i'm not going into debt to get this
promotion if you want me to have that
nicer truck by may first you're gonna
have to give it to me
and you won't give me a company car i'll
take a company card rather have that by
the way
if you you know if they want to
negotiate with you so but but they don't
they've already
they're they're their cfo has already
run the numbers he knows what he's doing
she knows what she's doing that's why
people are getting out of the company
car business
we see it all every day don't we oh yeah
i mean listen they know what they're
doing like you said the the financial
institutions these cfos
the numbers aren't stacked in your favor
so don't just take it as well i kind of
got to do it and this is a good thing
you know it kind of feels good
psychologically to hear the turnout
i got the 600 so i can use that for a
payment they go get like a 600
car payment it feels good it's not good
yeah so well
because you're stuck you are in you're
borrowing money for this major
corporation
and you're broke and they're not i mean
this is
this is this is it's the greatest scam
on earth
but um but it's part of the gig and i'm
you know you don't be mad about it i i
take
i take the job i think the job's a good
job um
especially right now man moving into
heavy equipment with this coming
economic boom and construction oh my
goodness
good time to be in construction so ken
good show today thank you sir always fun
that puts us
our of the ramsey show in the books our
thanks to james childs our producer
kelly daniel is our associate producer
and
phone screener i'm dave ramsey your host
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you